any social issue that we have in America
today
pick any social issue that we have in
the world today can and will be solved
by entrepreneurs if we allow to the
number one benefit America offers its
free enterprise its entrepreneurship and
it's for you to be able to do it at
whatever scale I feel if we encourage
more kids to want to go into
entrepreneurship if we encourage more
universities high school junior high
schools even elementary schools to start
talking about entrepreneurship kids are
gonna come up being inspired to saying
what problem can I sell and if we do
that we're gonna be okay that we're
trying to stay in the middle as much as
possible because there's a lot that the
left can learn from the right and
there's a lot that the right can learn
from the left I balanced those two out
if I go to someone's home and I say we
never watch Fox News you have blind
spots you have light spots and if I go
to someone's house and they said we
never watched CNN now you know that's
fake notes you have blind spots boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sake on for all you
newbies out there we are rebirthing the
public intellectual by hosting the
greatest minds of our time
I am super grateful to be on-site in
Dallas Texas at Value tainment we are
talking to entrepreneur author founder
of PHP people helping people agency the
fastest-growing financial services
company in America also value tame as
the number one entrepreneurship channel
on YouTube Patrick BETT David what's up
not much it's good to be all with you
thank you for the show I'm so so blessed
to have you on and you're a huge role
model for me and so many others that are
following their passions in life
figuring out how to become entrepreneurs
in this world and I and this has been
this has been a long ride for you you
have a lot of videos online of your path
how you got to where you
our and so I I want to focus a lot more
of our conversation on sort of the
higher level capitalism entrepreneurship
show conversations and you have had PHP
going on strong for almost ten years ten
years
yep and you have interviewed amazing
minds Kevin Hart
Magic Johnson Michael front say say
write yes and those conversations have
been you know in the multi millions of
views on your channel and you constantly
have content coming out about how to
make business plans or how to sell you
you you love selling and I love selling
- it's just so such an important trait
for us to develop over time so I want us
to talk about really this sort of where
we're at today with the sphere of
entrepreneurship and capitalism because
a lot of innovations in our world have
have electricity being innovated in the
internet and computers being innovated
even running water and ubiquity and food
and all these things had their just
increase the standard of life in the
quality of life and so the idea of these
things being not celebrated for some
reason the media is just straight-up
avoiding them by celebrating this type
of stuff tell us about your synthesis in
this moment yes I'll give you two
different perspectives on that yesterday
I'm with Anthony scale Moochie with
Bernard Kerik and with general
McChrystal in New York we're having
talks about different things and one of
the questions I proposed to Anthony
scaramouch and this is a good challenge
for you I said look a lot of people who
are Pro capitalists they believe in
entrepreneurship they believe in
business they are concerned about a guy
like Alex Jones being censored right and
getting a lot of people that are being
censor now this shadow band whatever you
want to call it Prager Jones Milo all
these guys and some people say this is
valid some will say it makes no sense
let them say whatever they want to talk
about I think the one challenge you face
is the younger generation coming up like
yourself who is concerned about the
future of capitalism and
entrepreneurship needs to consider
creating a platform
like a Facebook a YouTube a Twitter any
of those things a PayPal but politically
you may be on a complete opposite and
that's pro capitalism so you're not
going to be able to sound on a sensor
disc X I don't agree with you I'm gonna
censor you because I don't like what
you're saying you know it's like I don't
you're - Pro capitalism the younger
generation watching this let me put it
to you this way if there's ever been a
time for you to be able to create a
platform to compete with a YouTube
Facebook Twitter a PayPal any of that
stuff today's the time because you know
patreon look what happened with patreon
recently what they're doing with dave
rubin sam sam harris with jordan
peterson and these guys are lucky at
forget about it i'm no longer i think
sam harris just got off of a patreon and
he said moving forward i want you to
subscribe and donate to sam harris dork
/i think and subscribe i just gave him a
plug year but he says I'm not doing
patreon I'm gonna do my own thing now
Jordan Peterson is thinking about those
own things so anytime there's a major
push back you are giving strength to the
opposite side let me explain Bush gave
birth to Obama okay
Obama gave birth to Trump now whether
either one wants to take credit for it
that's just kind of how things work
you push far right in America we're
going left
you push far left in America we're going
right and generally the whole idea is
that we're trying to stay in the middle
as much as possible because there's a
lot that the left can learn from the
right and there's a lot that the right
can learn from the left now having said
that let's set that part aside the other
side about you said my synthesis is I'm
at Harvard Business School for the OPM
program I didn't go to Harvard Business
School I don't have a four-year or
two-year this is simply a owner
president management program that they
have you have to do minimum ten million
dollars per year or higher you go
there's about 140 students from 60 plus
countries and we spend three and a half
weeks together on campus it's a great
experience and one of the days twelve of
us were chosen to get up and give our
solution for the future I was one of the
presenters my message was around
education because my challenge is with
the education system and here's how I
saw the solution and the next thing you
know the next the presenter goes up and
he says here's the invention we've
created
how would you like it if we could
contact the mayor and predict an
earthquake from happening and giving
them a six minute warning what is that
worth so we're sitting there saying what
wait a minute what do you mean by that
think about it if we could say in the
next six minutes a 6.8 Richter scale you
know earthquake is about to hit your
city warning mayor handle and make your
decisions you have six minutes to tell
people to what evacuate get out maybe
we're gonna save thousands of lives what
is a product like that worth then
another guy gets up he's an entrepreneur
out of Africa Lagos he says we have a
water problem everybody around the world
is concerned about water well let me
tell you what we've invented for 100
million dollars we have invented a plant
a machine that through air creates water
and it can create upwards of 1 million
gallons of water per day what is that
word I'm just saying I'm just wondering
to my some like you know any social
issue that we have in America today pick
any social issue that we have in the
world today can and will be solved by
entrepreneurs if we allow - if you and I
were to play a game and let you say we
started a show his mother would this is
not a bad idea for somebody to do this
with their own YouTube channel say
here's your show you bring in five
entrepreneurs five thinkers so say for
instance you bring myself Jordan
Peterson sam Harris dave rubin ben
shapiro or you know a Gary a whoever
these entrepreneurs these people you
bring together and you say the game
we're gonna play today's I'm gonna give
you a problem you guys got one hour to
decide how we're gonna solve this
problem okay what's the problem how are
we gonna solve the issue we're facing in
Japan that has to do with X Y Z okay how
are we gonna solve the problem we're
facing in such-and-such city Detroit
that has to do with this okay here's a
problem you have one hour come up with a
game plan put five in a room with the
context we have the resources we have
the creativity we have look what happens
on an hour later in an hour let we have
to present it this is what we would do
we would contact Joe Joe knows this eye
contact the jack jack told me about this
person there's a technology that's
currently being used in Brazil that's
been this is patent right now level 3
patent
that thought that here's what we would
do to fix the issue in Detroit again I
feel if we encourage more kids to want
to go into entrepreneurship if we
encourage more universities high school
junior high schools even elementary
schools to start talking about
entrepreneurship kids are gonna come up
being inspired to saying what problem
can I sell and if we do that we're gonna
be okay
anything can be tackled by entrepreneurs
I believe that yeah I believe that
solving the world's biggest challenges
and even putting together some of the
greatest minds inside of rooms and just
throwing problems at them and saying all
right let's white let's whiteboard out
different solutions and then let's roll
with trying to execute those and see
what sticks in society to solve these
problems I am 100% with you on inspiring
the youth to care more about this so
let's touch on that what you have three
children you're we see so many kids
being born now into the information
technology generation and into this
exponential generation across all the
different pressing fields biotechnology
neuro technology artificial intelligence
blockchain and cryptocurrency all these
different texts are exploding so how do
we maximize the potential of the young
kids to potentially pursue
entrepreneurship you wrote the book drop
out and get schooled and so what do you
think about how we can do that well so
one if you want to talk at the
educational system I think everything is
changing everything is changing so fast
when I tell you everything the way we're
communicating the way we're doing
anything the highest paid youtuber last
year was a seven-year-old that made
twenty two million dollars let me say
this one more time the highest youtuber
last was a seven-year-old who made
twenty two million dollars you ought to
put the picture of it on Forbes when
they see this this is more than
pewdiepie more than Logan Paul more than
Jake Paul more than anybody twenty two
million dollars a seven-year-old Ryan
and what is he doing
reviewing toys with mom and dad you
think mom and dad thought this was gonna
be a twenty two million dollar passive
income one of their videos has 1.5
billion dollars and they think about the
slide 20
two million dollars it's an mba max
contract almost a max contract in the
MBA so what is that so
now imagine that kid going to school and
having to listen to a teacher telling
him how business doesn't work imagine
trying to explain to that seven-year-old
that creativity and all this edits are
trying to put them in a box I mean that
kid's gonna be like why are you doing
this to me this this is not fair I don't
like what you're doing to me right now
right so I think there's gonna be a part
of it where would access to so much
information I think the educational
system in a way is screwed this is why
they are going to be forced to change
force it's not and when I say force I
don't mean like a government force
this isn't like hey you better do it or
else we're gonna come up with a new
regulation and lobbyists are gonna go
out there make you come out with a new
curriculum nope
I'm sitting with the former president of
USC and we're there he's raising six
billion dollars he's a Greek fellow it's
an incredible guy and you know when and
whenever you're a president of a
university that big your job is to learn
how to raise money that's really your
strength they raise they bring people
that are great at raising money and he
says like I'm a professional beggar what
are you gonna do that's what I do for a
living so he's asking for six billion
dollars that they're raising
one-and-a-half billion dollars of it
goes a big number of it went to creating
a campus creating a local campus that's
1.5 million square feet give or take
that is identical to the cafeteria out
of Harry Potter that is identical to the
buildings out of Harry Potter think
about that here's a school like USC
Thurston and they're saying based on a
research we're doing kids are reading
Harry Potter they're studying Harry
Potter's they're fans of Harry Potter we
can't get rid of what JK Rowling did
with the most selling book in the
history of mankind outside of the Bible
and what's going on over here what is
this man doing what is going on with
these kids they want to go to a place
like this so they adapt they weren't
forced to do it they adapt it because
look I want to go to place that looks
like Harry Potter's cafeteria great well
we're willing to be creative I think the
educational system has to change
I don't think four years makes sense who
came up with four years was at a four
year strategic because it allows
to make money with you know the business
side of it I don't think the fact that
colleges are not paying taxes on their
sporting games so the money they make
from the sporting game the ticket they
sell they're not paying taxes on that
what does that have to do with education
the money they make under returns and
their accounts they're not paying taxes
on that why are they not paying taxes on
that there are so many incredible if you
want to start a business today to be a
billionaire go start a college I mean
truly every tax benefit favors colleges
and universities no one's saying
anything about it just hey we're gonna
pay for it because traditionally this is
what we've done but there's a big blue
ocean
if anybody's red blue ocean go reread it
again and find a way to crack the code
for the educational system there's so
much opportunity I think udemy
Pluralsight code Academy I think this is
just the beginning we haven't seen
anything yet that's gonna keep changing
but on the flip side of the coin with
these kids
I don't think educational system is
gonna have a lot of influence over five
six seven year olds as much as they
think because as long as YouTube is
around as long as you know these
platforms are around where my level of
curiosity is gonna allow me to go find
how to XYZ whatever X Y Z is I'm gonna
start saying oh my gosh like I can do
this and I can go out there and figure
out how to do this part and I can go
further ahead I do that part and what if
I can build this and what if I can build
that and then the kid is always gonna
compare the teacher on YouTube to the
teacher in school I think it's gonna say
I'm sorry teacher in school that that
person on that YouTube channel is just a
better teacher than you are I can't
listen to you I would much rather go
watch three hours of YouTube videos on
this person that I'm an admired them
then watching you so that comparison is
eventually gonna drive them nuts as like
a girlfriend constantly being compared
to the ex or boyfriend being compared to
the ex and no one likes that teachers
are gonna experience that and eventually
there's gonna be a lot of friction and
after that friction whenever we have
friction there is a solution always that
comes afterwards it's a lot of
difficulty but what do we like it or not
this is going to happen it is going to
happen and the change will be forced by
five six seven eight nine year old
guaranteed I see that happen X 5
- 15 years you're they're going crazy on
the social plans right now though even
children that are not yet birthed by the
parents the parents are making social
accounts for their children this is
going insane yeah and you're wondering
is that a good move is that a bad move
but imagine like 14 years old and your
mom gives your Instagram account here
sound here's your birthday present 18
thousand followers
I've been doing this since you were born
right think about that you're already an
influencer an influencer so Pat let's go
again
- that's let's explain this a little bit
because I don't think so many people
have a very global perspective on how
things are working in other places and
why the United States is such an
incredible ly fruitful place for
entrepreneurship and capitalism there
are so many places around the world
where there are structural violence is
in place that impede people from having
economic degrees of freedom in here we
have it so we need to celebrate that and
move forward and help other places in
the world enable their economic degrees
of freedom so they can also prosper yeah
so the question is you know given
perspective how do you give perspective
to people that are here who have never
seen it before right so yes that I'm
talking to general McChrystal who is a
four-star general like a four-star
general to me at any given time in the
US Army you can only have 14 four stars
so think about how many billionaires we
have in the world say we have a few
thousand billionaires handful of
billionaires there are only fourteen
four-star generals in the US Army that's
how big of a deal this is to be a
four-star I was in the Army for nearly
three years I never once met a one-star
let alone a four-star like four-star is
unreal right so I asked him about his
story his father was a two-star general
his grandfather's in the military as
well a leader also an officer his
brothers all went to West Point
he went to West Point he's one of four
sons that I believe went to was from
four or three that went to West Point so
in his family they grew up reading Greek
mythology Greek leaders just a
fascinating story right he wrote a book
called team of teams and he wrote
another recent book called leaders and
his perspective
different than some other generals so
it's interesting to find out about why
he thinks the way he does for him he
said something he says you know he grew
up in a family were what he knows is you
know being raised in a military family
his mom and that's it never did anything
wrong right never did anything wrong
he saw his mom and dad always doing the
right thing when they made a left and
they signaled they never winked and said
nobody saw us do this this is what he's
telling me okay so that perspective is
coming from a perspective of what man I
got so lucky being born in a family like
this because everybody else I heard
their family their families are flawed
issues drugs alcohol divorce separation
domestic violence all these other things
and you know people are raised oh my
goodness what's going on with this right
that example to me is the same exact
example of people who are born in
America and have never lived in another
place and they don't know how bad other
places is and sometimes we free yet it's
like the guy that's got a good father
who [ __ ] about his father and his
friend you know he [ __ ] about his
father to his friends and his friend
pulls him aside and says listen I wish
my dad was alive I wish I said please
don't complain about your father anymore
because it's so condescending to me
because I wish my dad was sitting right
here for me to have a five-minute
conversation while tears are coming down
his eyes and he's telling the story to
his friend and that's what a lot of
Americans are doing today you're talking
about America is this America is not
really great America is not really the
best country who said we're the greatest
country we need to stop with this
exceptionalism and you know America and
tongue all these things that you hear
about people that say that but they've
never lived in Iran they've never lived
in what's going on right now with France
look at the streets of France right now
what socialism is doing look at what's
going on France it's going on what's
going on in Spain look what's taking
place in some of these other countries
yeah look what's going on with people
that are in Cuba what's going on with
people in North Korea they don't know
better at some of these places you don't
even have access to satellite you know
the part that I am optimistic about when
I think about this is the following I
think like for me coming to America I
don't have a four-year I don't have a
two-year and I don't come from a family
of money my parents got a divorce my dad
was a cashier at a 99
store my mother relied a lot on welfare
and so I joined the army one day I'm
like listen I want to break from
everybody I'm going to the army and I go
to the army and I stayed it for three
years
Hunter furs airborne I come out I picked
up discipline I picked up focus I picked
up camaraderie those things from the
military I come out and I say let me get
this straight you mean to tell me in
America if I get to work and I figure
out a way to do something better I'm
allowed to make as much money as I can
and build a life I want to build yes let
me test this let me test it out - my
friends are graduate from USC UCLA
they're making sixty grand you're all of
Santa making 100 then I'm making a
quarter then I'm making a half then a
mil then all of a sudden we build a
business then I raise money then Oscar
De La Hoya is my business partner then
you've got Gabrielle Brenner was the
first Mexican born president Mexican
born professional sports owner in
America that invest into our company
Atalaya fund a two billion dollar fund
and the majority owner you go to crunch
base you read it while this is really
taking place why are you really making
money wow I can really push the envelope
with YouTube and really scale this and
build a platform and have a message that
would you like it or not because I don't
like this guy you don't listen to it I
like this guy you listen to it you mean
to tell me I can scale it this much yes
unbelievable why aren't more people
taking advantage of the biggest benefit
that this country offers it's like
working for a company that says when
they work for a company we give you free
membership to Equinox you have this much
money to spend for this we give you
scholarship to Toco to leadership
courses every up to three thousand
dollars as long as it's approved and
these are the seven things that you
prove you can go to Tony Robbins still
you can go to a leadership seminar USC
you can go to this thing by this where
you can go to a leadership thing over
here these are all approved as long as
you take it and you go and we have to go
with a partner from the company will
verify their benefits will give you 401k
benefits will give you stock options
will give out this say this company you
work for offers these 10 benefits but
you never take advantage of these 10
benefits whose fault is that the
employer or the employer
it's the employees fault America that
was a big country that offered all these
benefits the number one benefit America
offers is free enterprise its
entrepreneurship and it's for you to be
able to do it at whatever scale a lot of
people tell me and say geez
think everybody should be an
entrepreneur absolutely do you think
everybody can be an entrepreneur yes do
you think everybody can build a
billion-dollar company maybe not maybe
not a billion-dollar company but I
believe anybody can build a side
business making $3,000 a month I believe
anybody can build an online business
making two three four five thousand
dollars a month I believe anybody can do
something where once a week they work
somewhere they're making $500 a week I
think you can do that and I think you
ought to do that and then on the flip
side of it if that's free-market
capitalism free enterprise freedom of
assembly is another one that we don't
necessarily have in all countries but
freedom of speech look what you're doing
right now you're creating content you're
sharing your opinion here's what I think
here's what I believe you bring the
guest based on what you view as being
brilliant minds to somebody else I may
be an absolute crazy guy but to you you
may say I like the way he thinks I want
to put him on my platform let's see what
the viewers think about it
so on the in the direction we're going
with America and how the benefits this
country offers I think today you'll hear
say 90% of media is controlled by the
left right you'll hear saying that CNN
MSNBC NBC you know Washington Post Time
magazine LA Times New York Times you go
through all of it and then the right
owns what let's say they own you know
Fox News and that's pretty much it
maybe Washington Times but it's not as
big maybe New York Post but it's not New
York Times maybe some of these other
platforms
maybe the bright parts and all these you
know Drudge Report and some of these
things that's out there fine but
mainstream media is pushing so hard one
agenda that the next 10 or 20 years when
the other side of the media shows up
they can't get upset about it again this
is what this is what I'm thinking about
there's only so much I can push you
until you push me back like let you say
if I hit your knee right now first time
you may you react and say I don't know
what that was all about but out of
respect to my guess I won't do anything
right second time I dude you may say
Patrick can you please stop that hurt
third fourth fifth time how many times
can I do that I can't do that too many
times up to you react so you're either
gonna hit
are you gonna get up and say I'm sorry
this is weird I'm out of here right
you're gonna leave as bad as the
concerns may be from the capitalist
standpoint people that are worried about
what's gonna take place
I think this pushback is gonna create
the best innovators to pass calculus to
the best entrepreneurs
I think the tides gonna turn in ways
where they're gonna say what happened
and the message is gonna be simple you
gave birth to it yeah I really love how
you illustrated this benefits card that
every single citizen of the United
States is able to pursue yet so few
actually end up pursuing it and I think
there's a lot of social pressures the
parents the communities the people in
higher positions of clout there's so
much pressure on people saying follow a
path a certain path instead of make your
own path go and be an entrepreneur it's
not yet as celebrated as it could be and
hopefully with this new uprising in in
in in innovation in exponential
technologies that there will be more
entrepreneurs more celebrated and now
like you were explaining also with the
with access to information technology at
our fingertips anyone can more easily
create gives a degree of freedom and we
hope to see that around the world and we
hope to provide people with those
degrees of economic freedom around the
world okay so that's a lot on the on the
entrepreneurship and the capitalism side
of things I want to take a take a
transition to interviewing because this
has been something that you've been
picking up and it's been really fun
watching you in your interviews how has
this process been for you and what have
been some of your most profound
takeaways from interviewing so it's so
interesting you know I've been
interviewing my entire life and what I
mean by that is I've always been curious
so I always wanted to find out so you
know my family would say you would make
a good detective why I'm just curious
but it's not that I want to be a
detective I'm trying to find stuff out
right so when I was working in the
militant when I was in a military I
wanted to know I wanted to
you're from Mississippi what is it like
being from Mississippi like you said
Sioux Falls right I had a couple friends
I went to wedding for a guy that was
from North Dakota and I would ask him
what is North Dakota like tell me about
North Dakota I'll never forget what a
religion he was I never forget what the
wedding was like I never forget how he
was like his last name was Wilson nicest
guy in the world he lost his virginity
to his wife he never drank with us he
never partied with us how can you stay
so disciplined I was always curious with
that character my sergeants my officers
I was always curious so later on when I
got I started working at Bally Total
Fitness and I was selling memberships
but through selling memberships instead
of me sitting down with you and asking
you tell me some of your health goals
that you have do you want to get cut out
you want to lose weight you want to
increase energy do you want to put on
muscles what are some of your dreams and
goals and you would tell me how
important is it to you all that stuff
okay that's easy right and then I would
put a regimen you know program together
put you together with personal trying to
sell you membership whatever it was for
me i sat there and I said if I have 30
minutes with you to sell a membership
this is what I want to know I want to
know what career path you took what are
the benefits what are the pros what are
the cons what do you like about it would
you not like about it what is the
barrier to enter what degree do I knew
what kind of competition doesn't have
what kind of lifestyle potential does it
have do you like it do you not like it I
asked those questions and through that
is how I ended up in the insurance
industry believe it or not I would ask
real estate agents all the time what is
it to be a real estate agent give me the
pros and cons what do you like about it
well real estate agent there's a lot of
money to me my market goes up you make
money mark you go down you lose money
every 10 years in real estate you have a
divorce
you know I learned how to build a
rapport with people really well I did
because my favorite product in the world
some people like iPhones some people
like smartphones
some people like food my favorite
product in the world is people because
no two is the same mm-hmm so it's so
fascinating to learn about them I mean
how can you not get excited about
learning about people I ask you question
when you came I said tell me about
yourself and you were kind enough and
you kind of didn't want the attention to
be on you so you almost pushed back on
the answer three times but said I want
to know about you you're born what you
said October 10th
they your parents you're from Baku you
know your mom and dad over there your
dad's over there your mom's over here
tell me about the schooling why I
dropped out in 97 years ago or six years
ago I moved to Silicon Valley best
decision I made I was 19 year 26 now I
want to know I want to know how a person
is and so doing the interviews for me
one day we were like shout out right
there by the way that is how you build
relationships with people this is a
really important moment for people to
remember that if you care if you showed
true genuine love and care for asking
people questions about who they are and
what they care about in the world what
they want to build into the world and if
you can pair if you can paraphrase and
and show people that you actually listen
and that you care that that sort of
relationship building and like you are
snowflakes and since no one's had the
exact same stimuli that you've had in
your entire and I want to know about it
so I mean I know my life I want to know
your I'm gonna learn yeah so much to
learn right so from there then all of a
sudden interviews came up and when we
started doing these interviews the the
people being interviewed they're like
why do you know so much about me like
yesterday I'm sitting with Bernard Kerik
former chairman a former Commissioner of
NYPD in Commission of Correction NYPD
correction one of them was an 835
million dollar budget the other one was
a three and a half billion dollar budget
this kinds of going to prison he gets
hired by Bush to become the homeland
security head and then 11 days later
they find that he didn't pay taxes on
his nanny for 14 months and because of
that they put him in prison for three
years
couple other issues but they put him in
prison for three years and he lost his
entire reputation going back telling his
story at nine years old my mother got
shot and died because whatever she was
doing back in the days I'm sitting I'm
like fascinated by this story and he
says to me says how do you know the
meaning a head would push right before
that he landed back from Canada I said
it's called a research I'm curious about
your story you have an incredible story
and so I think there has to be a level
of curiosity especially if you like the
product if you like the product which is
people and I like people I mean I look
at people whether I agree with you or
not some people ask me and I say why
would you sit with a gloria allred
do you realize she's such a
there's so many words to use for Gloria
Allred there's so many words fused to
for Jerry Springer why would you sit
what Alex Jones on 9/11 what would you
sit with this other person you know
Katie Hopkins left right middle I don't
care I agree I disagree with you
criminal not criminal billionaire I want
to know because I think there's
something to learn from everybody good
bad or ugly so it's that level of
curiosity that makes these interviews
interesting to me yeah that's where I
love hello where you took that that's
that's right a level of curiosity and
also I would like to ask you about this
as well is you've built out this with
this level of curiosity you've built out
a mental lattice that has a lot of
different disciplines and life stories
baked into it so when someone starts
talking about what it's like to be low
socioeconomic status or high or what
it's like for them to have grown up in a
certain part of the world versus another
part of the world you can vibe with
people wherever they go and I we called
the polymaths one that has learned much
and so when you have that mental lattice
it helps you relate with people on a
deeper level and then also the emotional
intelligence the empathy that side of
things that you know how to how to how
to be present with someone on an
emotional level so we usually smash
those two things together and then you
gain some sort of a really strong
interviewing ability along with that
curiosity so do you where do you what
did you how do you feel about that sort
of about your own mental lattice now
being so multidisciplinary because you
have had so many people that you've sat
down with and asked I love how you said
you love people that's your favorite
product it is hands-down my favorite
products I you know I think it probably
you know people tell me they say you
know memory how can I get a better
memory
pay attention like like when you're
sitting with somebody you like if I can
if I can get to pour I'm sitting with
you no one exists around me I'm paying
attention if I'm around you and I'm
constantly worried about what happened
that what's going on with us what's
going on with us what's going on without
my wife my husband my kids might this
I'm a different place I may be getting
10% of what you were saying versus if I
can this can
than just be present with you I may be
able to get 40 50 % of it right so I
want to be present when I'm sitting down
with you but answer that question - I
think it probably gives you an edge on
knowing different rooms you can go enter
and you know how to handle topics and
discussions that come up to be able to
connect and that helps with business but
you there's got to be the desire behind
it like I can't force somebody to do
that I can show you the benefits of it
and tell yours a 10 benefits of you
being curious and how it's gonna
selfishly help you so in a way where you
do this you can advance some career 100%
because if you mean to tell me you sit
with your boss and you remember
something about your boss that somebody
else didn't remember they're gonna like
boss gonna say wait a minute how do you
remember that about me
I like this guy let me help this guy get
promoted what can I do to help you
advance people will remember those
things yesterday was my friend Phil hits
birthday
he's a seven-time mr. Olympia so hey you
know call to him and message to him
saying hey Phil happy birthday to you
man you know you're a champ you done
amazing things and even a simple
birthday sometimes we forget those phone
calls have so much influence but yeah
again I'm sure it helps but you it's got
to be important to you it's got to
matter to you to do it if it's to if
it's to strategic the opposition the
other person is gonna realize that
you're doing it with motives behind it
but if it comes from a sincere place
they won't know it's happening it just
kind of happens cuz it's sincere
as someone that has looked up to people
that are entrepreneurs that care a lot
about capitalist and they care a lot
about interviewing other people that
have an insatiable appetite for
knowledge in our world I am just I'm
connecting with you on a new on a very
new profound level for me too that I
just I love the idea of people being so
different and diverse and having a
desire to to get to know them I'm happy
that you're that here you're making that
really clear for us and I think if more
people had that we would humanize each
other more instead of the dehumanization
that's going on around the world in many
ways yeah the dehumanization can lead to
major problems I have a quick segue it's
here into into how this relates to the
future of society in general with
automation and artificial intelligence
robotics all these fields that are
booming what happens to human capital
human capital will be needed it'll be by
industry by industry case by case it
won't be every industry a lot of
industry is not going to necessarily
need the human capital as much as we
needed it before right I mean you heard
Elon Musk say the biggest thing we have
to worry about is the fact that AI could
be taken over everything that in the
future many jobs may not be there and
governments may need to support there
would he call it you know the the
populous because how they're gonna get
some income I don't know if we're going
to go that direction or not I don't know
what's gonna happen with that but I will
tell you that like today affiliate
marketing was not around 20 years ago at
least not at the level of today right
you tubers was not around 20 years ago
and there are people that make money
today that are youtubers right bloggers
was not around 20 years ago there wasn't
people doing blogs and getting
sponsorships people doing podcasts
nowadays making a half a million dollars
here as a podcaster yeah I met a man who
was an attorney making two hundred
grandeur he drops being a attorney goes
and becomes a podcaster because he's a
die-hard Walt Disney fan Disney World
find he's making a half
dollars here from sponsorships all he
ever talks about is Disney any is no
longer an attorney so there's gonna be
so many new ways to make money I think
the one skill set that's gonna be very
very critical is learning how to adapt
and and when I say adapt
I mean adapt quickly and it's gonna kind
of hurt the older community because
typically the older community doesn't
adapt that quickly they go back to
trying to change people like you know I
don't understand these Millennials
they're just so weird they're lazy I I
call him he doesn't pick up I text him
he responds back why don't you call me I
want to hear your voice you have to
adapt
they're not gonna adapt to you you have
to adapt to them you don't know what it
is to go to school with a cell phone
that nine years old you don't know what
they know it you and I didn't get a cell
phone say they're good people that my
age maybe at 21 for some I got a cell
phone I was 21 I was listening to
Walkman until I was 20 I got my first CD
player at 21 I didn't come from money
but that's the adjustment we used to
pull our windows up right to date song
you know automatic well you don't even
think about cars that are manual for the
window your own you know everything is a
machine so that's not making that big of
a difference in our lives I think the
skill is gonna be adapting and actually
sitting down and asking yourself the
question for instance I'm in the life
insurance business you know I start off
on a financial industry and then at one
point I had to decide what part of it I
wanted to go to I start off with Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter day before 9/11 so I
got my series 766 31:26 life and health
right and in all of a sudden during that
time you started seeing short rate
Scotch rate each rate you know all these
do it yourself do it yourself do it
yourself 999 a trade and if you do more
than 100 trades I'm on 299 or trade and
so everything was about you can buy the
stocks yourself you no longer need to
stock brokers I said first so why would
I go that route of being a stock broker
if every time I want to be compared to a
machine let's just say they come up with
the right predictive analytics that says
don't buy this stock buy this stock
based on these why am I need it my brain
is never going to be smarter than a
computer that has access to data that
can do math within the second and I can
do complex math and I'm pretty good at
math so maybe being a stock
is not the route to go then I looked at
the other sets of bonds okay I don't
know bonds is gonna be tied to the same
thing money under manager maybe it's not
a bad idea to do money under management
okay I'm gonna do that two percent you
know anywhere between a half a percent
to two percent different depending on
the market you're dealing with but then
looked at PNC auto insurance they passed
the law you have to have auto insurance
or else you know you're gonna get a
ticket so at that moment I no longer
needed an auto insurance agent we just
buy auto insurance 15 years when I said
with a person mercury auto insurance I'd
buy it from you I haven't met my most
last auto insurance agent for last 15
years because I don't need it today it's
a machine I call I set it up so auto
insurance went out of business but life
insurance why'd I stay in a life
insurance business because no one buys
life insurance
everybody's sold life insurance and life
insurance is never gonna be a law for
you to have life insurance it's always
gonna be I have to convince you to buy
life insurance you don't wake up in the
morning saying honey I feel like buying
life insurance today no one does that
you got to be educated on the importance
of it yes and it's an emotional sale
auto insurance is a logical sale
life insurance is an emotional sale
Johnny what are you going to do if God
forbid something happens to you you have
a wife you have three kids your wife
only makes 40 grand you make 150 your
she can't survive on her 40 what are you
gonna do do you want your wife to rely
on another man to take care of your kids
and be forced to appease to the new
men's rules or do you want to make sure
that she dictates what the family rules
are gonna be based on the way you left
your family behind and it's like and she
thinks about another man that she could
possibly marry says oh hell no I need a
lot 1 million-dollar life-insurance
policy that's an emotional right so the
life insurance industry's not gonna take
a hit so I'm going back in all I'm
thinking about is the part of AI you
know everything's gonna be affected by
air no matter what but it'll be case by
case and you have to sit there and think
about yourself within your industry and
say how is this thing gonna be hit by
robots in AI and if it is you better get
your adapting muscle ready because
things are gonna adjust on the flip side
of a for the people that are
opportunistic
it's a great time to become a
billionaire there's many ways to become
a billionaire right now if there's a
time that you can make millions hundreds
of millions billions the next 10 or 20
it's gonna be the best time ever where
someone's gonna pop out with some idea
that's gonna be picked up by somebody so
I'll pay 1.8 billion dollars for that my
name is Google
I'll pay you 600 million dollars my name
is Facebook I'll pay you 800 million
dollars my name is Jeff Bezos I'll pay
this much money my name is Walmart it's
a very good time to be an innovator
today very mmm-hmm yeah yeah and there's
so much to be able to build with the new
infrastructures in place and the more
degrees of freedom that pop in places
like Africa the more of these beautiful
innovations that we're gonna start
seeing around the world and it's gonna
go from 1,500 billionaires to 3,000 been
the blink of an eye no doubt about yeah
and what are they gonna build and
hindsight's always gonna be 2020 we're
gonna be like I I thought I knew that
that would be that that would have been
a good idea so yeah be that be the
person that innovates go and build into
the world you guys always know that were
we're talking about that with a lot of
intensity as do you which is one of the
reasons why I love you so much you talk
about building and creating with so much
intensity you even take this to PHP
we're starting talking about your agency
a little bit I found it so interesting
that the agency itself has a very strong
footing in helping the your individual
financial services the service year the
individuals that are that are the eight
your agents are not only agents of the
financial services and educating
customers but they're also working on
their own individual brands and that you
guys help teach them how to do that that
is the new age hmm I love that oh yeah
absolutely because you know so for me I
was coming up in this company and they
said you can't build your own brand on
Facebook or YouTube you have to
profoundly befriend me you have to do
this and you have to unlock wait a
minute what do you mean I can't do that
and then I sat there and I said my gosh
this is how other people are going to
feel if they want to build a brand I am
too confined and what if you get the
Tasmanian Devil you think you can really
confine and control the Tasmania
devil there's no way in the world he's
got to go out and figure himself out and
sometimes he's gonna break a few things
but it's a person like that it's gonna
be able to take you to a whole different
level I said we can embrace it so what
we did is we came out with a system like
we would sit down with one of our guys
and we have one guy named Matt Zapata
money smart guy if you look up his
handle and he's a Marine
eight years in the Marines he served war
all over the place he's got incredible
stories but then he had his own TV show
on Finance in Chicago he would go on
panels he was always on WGN with him and
Chris Gardner because Chris Gardner from
Pursuit of Happyness he's also a Chicago
guy and they would go out there and talk
about different kinds of things so he
and I were introduced to each other by
Dudley Rutherford a pastor and we
connected and he says that you guys got
to talk he's Filipino you're Middle
Eastern you guys are like brothers from
you know different mothers right now
second let's get let's talk then we
connected then I said listen man why
don't you brand yourself as the veteran
entrepreneur it's just what do you mean
I said there's 31 million veterans in
America some active some inactive they
need help you're gonna speak their
language this is at a 330 million people
31 million is nine and a half percent a
big population so he did next thing you
know he has all these different events
that he's doing with military folks
veterans he's being contacted by the
Marines by Air Force by Navy by army
he's doing so much work for the veterans
and he's making a 7-figure your income
he's been with us for three years
in the first three years we paid him 2.7
million dollars that's not bad but our
focus became selfishly what brand do you
want to build what is your cause what
does you crusade let's help you get
doing that and on top of that you build
a business today you got two brands
you're building your business and your
personal brand you got to make sure you
do both today yes yes and I wanna see if
we can see the transition with like you
were just describing the you're building
a personal brand you're building a
business brand you're doing those at the
same time you yourself are the people
that work with you are you're inspiring
them to now people from around the world
are starting to do that what are your
thoughts about the current state of the
geopolitical climate because there is a
lot going on
around the world economically
politically the way that commodities are
moved around the world the way that
exponential technologies are coming
forth what do you see as going on today
that is really important to keep an eye
on I think you know the whole saying of
I just don't pay attention to politics
it's too dirty you know I I just don't
want to deal with politics maybe you
could have said that 30 years ago can't
say that today you cannot say that today
you have to pay attention to politics
today and by the way this is not a you
know a democratic message or a
Republican message or independent
libertarian message
this is just a self-awareness is a being
aware of what's going on in a
marketplace message because I heard a
quote one time was I think it was by
Plato that said those who believe it's
foolish to study politics will be led
and ruled by those who do okay so
remember those who believe it's foolish
to study politics will be led by fools
who do so if you don't study what's
going on a marketplace you're gonna be
led by somebody else who does so what's
my feedback to you how to handle it you
got to subscribe to three four different
writers sites
I like Business Insider there's certain
things I like and you got to subscribe
to both someone on the Democratic side
and you got to subscribe to someone on
the Republican side any time Trump does
something right and oh my gosh on fox
news like I look what Trump this may be
the greatest president of all time I go
straight to MSNBC and CNN every time any
time CNN MSNBC saying something about
look at Barack Obama he's the greatest
president of all time I go straight to
Fox News I balanced those two out if I
go to someone's home and I say we never
watch Fox News you have blind spots your
vice your light spots and if I go to
someone's house and they said we never
watch CNN now you know that's fake notes
you have blind spots so this isn't the
idea like for me I read Karl Marx
Communist Manifesto and I read Atlas
Shrugged but I think for some people
that's I would never read at this at
some other it said I would never read at
the shrug that Ayn Rand's selfish bi TCH
I can't believe she is this and ask some
people that say I would never read rules
for radicals and Karl Marx Communist
Manifesto I would ever do that now you
get you got a
make sure you read them all to be able
to have your blind spots being covered
because you're like okay this guy says
that capitalism works because of this
but but Karl Marx's capitalism doesn't
work because you become so competitive
in the marketplace that you forget about
your family
and so this is why it's better for us
all to be at the same level I don't know
if I agree with this but maybe he's got
a good point with the families I don't
know if I agree with do you have to come
up with your own stuff as you're doing
this but a lot of times you'll see
someone that's politically left because
their parents were left and their
grandparents were left with and that's
your blind spots you know and you know
for me my mother's side they were
Communists they all believed in
communism I mean they're from Baku your
family's from Baku and they escape from
Baku and they went to Caspian Sea
through Caspian Sea me they went to a
place called Bandar Pallavi Rashed it's
no longer called Bandar pala be after
the regime change but they lived there
but they still had some ties to
communists ik society they liked it it
was warm it was fuzzy my dad believed in
imperialism the Shah today I have one of
Sean's former soldiers that's coming
here to visit with me who became a
Special Forces in u.s. he was the first
Muslim Special Forces soldier in the US
Army and he went back to Iran to help
out with Jimmy Carter about the whole
you know embassy was being attacked and
I want to know hear his story but you
gotta listen to both perspectives so
going back to geopolitical and what to
do with it man stares and touches
possible was in London last week and I
want to set them with three different
types of people all different
personalities and beliefs politically
because I want to know what's going on
in brexit how is brexit affecting you
know you got 28 nations that are part of
you one wants to come up and Britain
wants to be their own deal and they got
voted for but they're trying to fight
back and they're trying to get them back
in the EU and the EU is way of selling
the messages well you know if you're
part of the EU we are officially the
third largest military in the world if
we all come together but then folks in
Britain or complaining yeah but it's the
higher economies that are taking care of
people like Greece who are not that
discipline and it's like kind of like
socialism is what you is they're the
ones that are doing it right or taking
care to people that are screwing around
I don't want to be a part of it now
there's seven other nations want to
leave it how does that impact Europe
could they be a war is it a good thing
what benefits is that I want to know
yeah and so you know I think it's
important
to realize I don't I don't know all the
things that are going on
obviously what's going on with the
tariffs in China how is that gonna
affect the economy is the negotiation
gonna affect us negatively positively
March 1st 2019 is a big day because
we're gonna find that if that day's
gonna happen or it's not gonna happen so
you got to somehow stay connected and I
think if you do again staying connected
to geopolitical paying attention to
industries that are changing and what
regulations are changing allows you to
adapt faster and whoever adapts faster
has an edge over those that adapt slower
if you adapt to slow well you're gonna
be you know predicator based on what
everybody else does then you do what
they do but if you're able to adapt fast
based on information that you have and
the trends that you're studying I think
you have a big edge so I my biggest
thing has always been just pay attention
to politics I know you don't like it I
know it's ugly just pay attention to it
a little bit more than you're doing yeah
this actually looped us all the way back
to developing out that mental lattice
and having it be as multidisciplinary as
possible seeing the beauty in different
styles of people and how they've evolved
into our world okay a couple of power
round thoughts on the way out Patrick
what do you think exists outside as of
us as a higher power got it so your time
I like a god let you tell us something a
higher power that's the direction going
yeah and what would potentially even
exist outside the 3d reality that we got
have been you know I've read a book the
other day that talks about you know
sometimes you have to figure out a way
to get disconnected with everything you
know to tap into possibilities that are
not necessarily there because you've
been conditioned to think in a certain
way so you have to disconnect to be able
to go a little loose and this is a
community that says maybe it makes sense
to do shrooms and all these other there
really is a community that talks about
that enough you read about we've had
Rick Doblin the exec director of maps
multi display association for
psychedelic scientists and studies and
that is a huge
waited to eradicate traumas from PTSD
and a lot of other really important very
interesting and why would they have
research to show like I'm not of that
school I'm the one that didn't want to
touch drugs I'm the guy that didn't like
it I'm not saying I didn't do a couple
of things to try them out but I was
always like trying to figure out control
I don't want to be controlled by drugs
but you know higher law okay let's talk
about that look no matter what's out
there no one knows a hundred percent
what's out there the Atheist could be
wrong or right the agnostic could be
right or wrong the Christian the
Catholic the Baha'i the Muslim the
seven-day the Scientologists every one
of them's either gonna be right or wrong
right so for me back in 2002 2004 five I
went on a journey I said I just want to
find out about all these religions so I
went to Scientology and I started
studying Scientology Dianetics because
that a lot of Scientologists around me
then I went to Catholics and I wanted to
study what made Catholics so special
well I realized they're more about
rituals and their rituals is incredible
on what they've done
then I when I studied more minutes of
LDS Joseph Smith what is this whole
thing with book of Moroni and how he
started in Vermont and he found these
special plates and they started going
different places and I finally in Utah's
where they stayed and they figured that
was a place for them to start their
religion so Brigham Young cuz the guy
that's moving it around Jehovah's
Witness why did he believe in what they
believed in why don't they celebrate
birthdays and Christmas why is it that
they think what they think seven day
Adventists so they're thinking simply
was a Saturday not a Sunday - that's the
biggest disconnect so Muslim what is the
Muslim the you know what is the
difference between Islam and Muslim and
book of Quran and this whole thing you
read about you know Mohammed you know
was he a good man was he not a good man
why say the criticism you know why
Solomon Rush is saying what he's saying
so I went through this whole period I
was an atheist 25 years of my life I
didn't believe in God I went to church
and I would always get kicked out of
Bible study in Iran and so you mean to
tell me there's a God and we just got
bombed and 200 people died and you want
me to believe there's a god if there was
a God he's strong enough to hold the
bomb and not a little drop off so that's
the conflict right why is it that good
people that why is a six-year-old kid
that has an experienced life yet all of
a sudden get cancer
and and she dies in the arms of her
mother no mother should be holding a
six-year-old daughter in her arms and
loosing it that's a very emotional pain
that she's probably gonna experience for
the rest of her life to overcome that
that's like 60 years of pain you just
gave to a human being I don't know so I
struggled with it a lot and and
eventually for me it came too seriously
a bet like you have to bet on something
and say that's that's where I'm going
and I could still be wrong so I bet on
that there is a God to me there's too
many weird situations that there is and
there's and I'll give you a weird story
here very weird story or I got out of
the Army and I'm dating a woman so love
of my life she's from baku i was telling
about her earlier and we're in the car
we've been together for three years I'm
in a worse position in my life I'm broke
forty nine thousand dollars of debt I
have nothing going on in my life and I
want to be with the skrull but I can't
afford to do anything I mean I can't
afford to take her to movies and we're
at Universal Studio City Walk we're
upstairs in a parking lot she gets in a
car she lives in her Integra black
Integra and I'm on my black expedition
and I'm sitting there I got out of the
army I haven't spoken to my mom for five
years I have a new phone
she doesn't know my phone number it's
two o'clock in the morning okay and I'm
sitting there and I say you know what
god I'm crying like a baby I said god I
don't believe you exist I don't believe
you exist but if you do I want to hear
my mom's voice right now
suck it just a child one of yours mom's
voice when I tell you 30 seconds later
my phone rang with a block number I was
so scared to answer the phone so scared
to answer the phone okay so I had one of
those Nextel walkie talkie phones you
know the ones that you would go like
this back in the days and I answer the
phone and it's her crime so why are you
crying and I'm crying but she cried
first I'm like why are you crying she
says because God told me you were I'm
paying out to call you I'm like what do
you mean come on
and like I just got the chills out on my
buttocks that gets scared every time
this happens like for me it's like that
real and I said what do you mean how'd
you get my number
well I've had your number for the last
six months I just didn't want to call
you she was upset I joined the army
and I said um I'm just like I can't even
talk to her what's going on I can't I
can't even tell her what I'm experienced
in that moment because it wasn't about
her at that time it was like a
supernatural I'm not the guy that smokes
weed or does any of that stuff and so
awesome like what the hell is going on
here this could be real like is there
really higher power if somebody really
listened to me and if it is what is the
potential of what I can do with this
person that listens to me that's a
higher power and then from there took me
you know when you read Malcolm
Gladwell's book David and Goliath
sometimes when people that are close of
dying but they don't die they believe
there's a destiny tight and I'm like
you're supposed to do something is this
a mathematical formula am i destined I
feel like God's using me in a way to do
something big with my life but what is
it what is the purpose how come I don't
know yet why don't you telling me so
that's the battle so till today I am NOT
the guide that goes around baptizing
people I'm the guy that's full of doubts
and questions and virgin mary and i've
sat down and I've gone through all these
prophecies and how is that even possible
and but 2,000 years prior to that there
was another religion that used the same
formula so is it real is it not real how
can that happen that can't happen
scientifically it's happened before so
why is it such a big deal for you to
believe this and not believe this so all
of these things combined together got me
to finally say I think there is I just
don't know hundred percent so I think
there is a God and I'm putting my bet
that there is and piggybacking on that
do you think that this is a simulation I
have no idea man
but it's okay if it is mmm but I have no
idea I am very comfortable if it is I'm
very comfortable if that is what's
taking place there's one thing that I
don't have any desire to being zero I
think that's the problem sometimes there
are a lot of people that want to be God
I have zero desire to be God and it
makes me what that means to me I want to
know I'm curious I want to learn a lot
but I don't want to be God because if I
aspire to want to be like some religions
sell you on if you move up these points
and you become a 23 you become your own
God and one day when
you have you in universe you would never
convince me to get baptized in that
religion sorry I don't aspire to want to
be good I don't care to be God I don't
want to be God
so if that is happening I am very okay
playing that role and I'm gonna do my
best to be a good character in that
movie let's just say that is taking
place you know but for me it's more
about controlled decision making process
that increases my odds of putting myself
in the right position to make impact and
if I do that right that's what good with
that last question what do you think's
the most beautiful thing in the world
people man yeah people it's the most
beautiful thing it's it's the most
beautiful thing so for me I
intentionally like to sit with people I
disagree with yeah because I want to get
their perspective yes I want to learn
from them it's very easy to only sit
with people you agree with that's an
easy conversation but it's sitting with
people they disagree with their decision
let's say how did you get to that point
I think I learned more like that but yet
people is the most beautiful product in
the world I love it Patrick this has
been so so enriching across a bunch of
different ways of perception and this
has been amazing thank you so much for
joining John thank you sir thank you
yeah thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you also going to check out
Patrick's links in the bio below go and
check all that out go and follow value
tame it and go and start checking out
the channel also go and build the future
manifest your destiny into the world
everyone bring your calling forth we
love you so much thanks for tuning in
and we'll see you soon take care
[Music]